مركز هذا الزلزال كان ولايه كهرمان مرعش
كهرمان
بدا من هنا وانتشر بموجاته في العشر
ولايات الاخرى
عدد الوفيات الان ثمان الاف 800
واربعه وسبعين
وعدد المباني المنهاره هو
افاده من
6400 مبنى
طبعا من المهم الى نقطه مهمه هنا
هناك صبر
واعتقد ان الشعب الان والمواطنين سيظهرون
هذا ايضا باستمرار
هنا في كل
المدن المتضرره من هذا الزلزال افادت
تتراس عمليه التنسيق هو الانقاذ والبحث مع
البلديه ومع القوات الاخرى والفرق الاخرى
في كل مدينه
[موسيقى]
يتابع كل المجريات
وفي اليوم الاول طبعا وجهنا بعض المشاكل
في الوصول الى المناطق المنكوبه والى
المباني ولكن الان استطعنا ان نسيطر
بحجم كانوا بنسبه ممكنه الى هذه
المدن وصن الى هذه المدن وايضا المباني
ولكن الان نعمل
عمليه رفع الانقاض كلها
المنطقه في اسرع وقت ممكن
طبعا الحد
لهذا
الموجود وسنحقق الاعمار في سنه
التي حصلت في
الاشهر وسنوات الماضيه في عدد مختلف من
المدن
لن نترك اي مواطن في الشارع بالطبع سنساعد
الجميع وسنقدم المساعدات للجميع علينا ان
ننوه ايضا
انطاليا الانيا مارسن في انطاليا ومرسين
والانيا
طبعا هناك فنادق في انطاليا
ونستمر بالحديث وايه هو
التواصل واياهم
ونحن سنوجه المواطنين ايضا الى هناك
المتضررين من الزلازل الى سنرسلهم الى
هناك
وسنؤمن لهم الاقامه في هذه الفنادق في
الانيا وانطاليا
الى عدد غرف لا باس به يمكن للمتضررين ان
يقيموا هناك طبعا من الممكن ان يكون
المتضررين من الزلزال سعيدين هنا نحن نعلم
ان المخيمات ظروفها صعبه واذا وافقوا على
التوجه الى هذه المدن فنحن سنساعدهم
بالذهاب الى هذه المدن والاقامه هناك
وسناؤهل لهم كل الامكانيات لكي يقيم هناك
بشكل مؤقت الى ان يتم اعمار هذه المناطق
وطبعا سيتم تحديد
المنسقين في هذا الاطار
[موسيقى]
ليحملوا لينقلوا عفوا
المتضررين من هذه الزلازل الى المدن
الاخرى انطاليا
اقامتهم هناك في حال طبعا النقل
المواطنين من هنا الى تلك المدن فنسهل
ايضا عمليه
الانقاذ والبحث هنا اكثر في البدايه كان
هناك مشاكل في الطرق في المطارات ولكن
الان نحن حققنا
تامين هذه الطرق وتامين المطارات هناك بعض
المشاكل ايضا في تامين بعض
المحروقات مثلا او المواد الاخرى ولكن
نتغلب عليها شيئا فشيء ميلونجاز وايجاز
ايضا
يساعدوننا في تقديم المحروقات وانابيب
الغاز ايضا الى هذه المدن من اجل تامين
الطهي والدفء وايضا الاحتياجات الاخرى
لذلك
من المهم الان العمل على
تامين العيش بشكل كريم هنا ونحن طبعا
سنؤمن كل الاحتياجات هنا ولكن من الافضل
اذا استطعنا ان ننقل المصابين او
المتضررين من
الزلزال بدل يقيموا في هذه المخيمات
بامكانهم ان يقيموا فيه الفنادق في المدن
المختلفون نحن سنؤمن لكل اجور ذلك ايضا من
المهم جدا عدم السماح
للتصريحات
الاستفزازيه والاخبار المستفزه وايضا
الاخبار الكاذبه التي تنتشر على موقع
التواصل الاجتماعي من المهم الان ان نركز
على عمليات البحث والانقاذ والتضامن في
هذا الاطار هناك بعض الاستعدادات
لتشخيص الاضرار الموجوده هنا في هذه المدن
ايضا سنقدم الدعم للاسر المتضرره من هذه
الزلازل تم تحديد بعض
في متابعه لكلمه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان اثناء تفقه لموقع مركز الزلازل في
ولايه قهرمان مرعش اردوغان مشاهدينا قال
واجهنا مشاكل في الوصول للمناطق المنكوبه
والاستجابه للزلازل لكن العمليات عادت
لطبيعتها قال ايضا وتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد
القتلى الى ثمانيه الاف وخمسمائه واربعه
وسبعين قتيلا وقال سنساعد الجميع ولن نترك
مواطنا في الشارع وسنتصرف سريعا بعد
اردوغان ايضا وقال سننهي اعاده اعمال
المناطق المتضرره خلال عام واحد